[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم مصيبه شابا
فلسطينيا واعتقل ثلاثه اخرون خلال اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم
بلدتي قباطيه والزبابده جنوب محافظه جنين
بالضفه الغربيه وقال جهود عيان ان مواجهه
اندلعت بين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
اثناء الاقتحام
قالت مصادر الدبلوماسيه للجزيره ان مجلس
الامن الدولي سيعقد جلسه مفتوحه غدا
الخميس لمناقشه تطورات في المسجد الاقصى
وكلف الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس بعثه
بلاده في نيويورك بالتحرك الفوري في الامم
المتحده ومجلس الامن لادانه ووقف
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه المتواصله على
المسجد الاقصى
عرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
معارضه بلاده لاي اجراءات احاديه تقود
الوضع الراهنه في الاماكن المقدسه بالقدس
واقال ان زياره وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اثمار بني كبير لباحات الاقصى
قد تؤدي الى اثاره العنف
عبرت حركه النهضه التونسيه عن تضامنها
الكامل مع كل المعارضين المستهدفين من
السلطه واعتبرت في بياننا ان استهداف
المعارضين للرئيس قيس سعيد تصعيد ممنهج
اعتبارته تصعيدا وخطيرا لا سيما انه يمر
عبر الضغط على القضاه بغايه الترهيب
والتنكيل بالمعارضين حسب بيان الحركه
في الاثناء شددت رئيسه الحكومه التونسيه
نجلاء بدر خلال لقائها مع الامين العام
لاتحاد الشغل ورئيس اتحاد الصناعه
والتجاره على ضروره تنقيه المناخات العامه
والعمل المشترك وتغليب المصلحه العامه
لايجاد الحلول الملائمه وتوفير سبل نجاح
في المرحله القادمه
قال قائد الجيش الاوكراني انه بحث مع رئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه مارشميل
الاحتياجات بلادي العسكريه من اجل مواصله
القتال ضد روسيا معتبران ان زياده قدرات
الجيش الاوكراني من شانها ان تضمن الامن
في جميع انحاء اوروبا اشار قائد الجيش
الاوكراني الى ان الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات التي حصلت عليها كيف بمساعده
واشنطن تساعد في انقاذ ارواح الاوكرانيين
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى من العسكريين الروس نتيجه قصف مركز
تابع للجيش في مدينه الى 89 قتيلا وقال
نائب رئيس الاداره العسكريه بالجيش الروسي
ان التحقيقات الاوليه تشير الى ان استخدام
الجنود للهواتف المحموله كنسببا في كشفهم
اخفق مجلس النواب الامريكي في التوافق على
مرشح لرئاسه المجلس بعد ثلاث جولات من
التصويت وعلق المجلس جلساته الى ظهر اليوم
الاربعاء وقد فشل زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
218 صوتا المطلوبه لتولي الرئاسه
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء